dans notre journal d'hier soir je vous
faisais part de la décision du maire de
montfermeil de ne pas inscrire 33
enfants immigrés dans les écoles de sa
commune ce soir on apprenait que le
maire de montfermeil accepté d'inscrire
les enfants
après rencontre avec le préfet nous
avons invité monsieur pierre bernard
lemaire divers opposition de montfermeil
pour s'expliquer sur ce plateau alors
pourquoi ce revirement monsieur le maire
seulement parce que monsieur le préfet
de seine-saint-denis
ma mise en demeure d'avoir à inscrire
les enfants des écoles et devant une
mise en demeure je n'ai plus que
m'incliner donc vous inscrivez les
enfants qui n'étaient pas inscrits donc
j'inscris les enfants qui n'étaient pas
inscrits tous depuis le 25 octobre
tous nous inscrivons 21 enfants dans les
classes primaires et les aux enfants
maternelle nous nous inscrivons pas si
demain matin un enfant bien s'inscrire
tous ses parents est ce que vous
l'espérez non monsieur donc votre
rencontre avec le préfet n'a servi à
rien elle a servi quand même a refusé
toujours d'appliquer la loi donc si vous
voulez je refuse d'appliquer la loi mais
le problème que vous porter
essentiellement sur le fait d'enfants
non inscrits à l'école n'est pas là le
problème est une question dit me grise
d'immigration enfermait les enfants ils
ont quand même bien droit ils sont dans
votre commune vous devez désinscrire non
c'est la loi c'est la loi peut-être mais
en attendant la ville de montfermeil
n'est n'est pas la ville où tous les
enfants et la population immigrée de se
rejoindre en france de 8% dû migrer
pourquoi y'en a t'il 25% à montfermeil
royal à 25% à montfermeil must pour
prier allah 25% à montfermeil c'est
parce que les gens sont venus dans une
résidence essentiellement dont des
locaux des locataires des locataires
uniquement des locataires wii sont lus
dans une résidence ce qui les
accueillent
parce que la population française ne
tient peut-être plus tellement et y
aller en raison de leur nombre ils sont
60% dans cette scène résidence ce qui
est affecté dans ce sens pour lequel la
solution selon vous la solution elle
elle a connu une amorce une amorce par
le fait que nous avons cherché avec le
département et l'office départemental
des hlm
nous avons cherché des financements qui
pouvait permettre cette dernière c'est à
dire le 6
d'acquérir un certain nombre
d'appartements sur cette résidence je
n'aime pas les attributs et des immigrés
normalement si nous parlons de l'égalité
on n'a pas le droit de dire ça c'est
vous qui le dites il me vient ce n'est
pas d'accord au nom de l'égalité
également je crois que on n'aurait pas
le droit de ne refuser un logement à
quelqu'un c'est ce que vous faites pour
les écoles c'est ce que j'ai fait pour
les écoles mais le ballon je m'appelle
fait paradoxal mais c'est quand même le
problème de la vie de famille dans votre
commune c'est un paradoxal ce que vous
dites là mais je ne suis pas le
président de l'office dès maintenant
mais les chalets inscrivez les enfants
dans les écoles de votre commune six
mois casque et les enfants mais ce n'est
pas moi qui joue les appartements bon
finalement qu'est ce qui va se passer
maintenant vous re vous vous faites
toujours le bloc bloquaient toujours la
situation je suis obligé parce que aussi
longtemps qu'on n'aura pas résolu le
problème de pénétration d'immigrés à
montfermeil
il reste en caisse que vous risquez
monsieur au regard de la loi si vous ne
l'appliqué pas
le mais je l'appliquerais si jamais le
presser de la ligne me remets en hummer
oui mais il est possible que demain le
préfet me remette en demeure de
de réinscrire de nouveaux enfants y
allons pour le ferai mais si je suis en
mis en demeure
zizou condamner tout cela va-t-il aller
parce que cela va aller jusqu'au moment
où on aura trouvé la solution et
j'espère que nous allons la trouver au
regard de l'immigration parce que le
problème est là le problème ne ce n'est
pas 30 enfants qui pendant un mois n'ont
pas été à l'école parce que il ne faut
pas traumatiser ce n'est que la sphère
d'un mois c'est grave je conviens mais
ce n'est pas catastrophique
ces enfants vont donc être inscrit mais
maintenant pour nous allons avoir une
table-ronde parti d'en rire une
table-ronde table ronde le préfet
d'accord à le préfet c'est lui qui doit
organiser voyez très bien donc nous
espérons que ça viendra très bientôt
parce que c'est là où est le problème
merci d'être venu sur ce plateau pour
nous avoir donné ces explications des
taxis